SuperMario Odyssey is officially out and
if you're hoping to put some of your own
Meebo figures to good use now is
definitely the time some of them will
give you special in-game bonuses for
example tap a peach amiibo while playing
and you'll be given some extra hearts so
use that when you need a little
pick-me-up or tap any Mario amiibo and
I'll grant you 30 seconds of
invincibility but if you're not
impressed with these perks and one see
the full power of the amiibo you'll need
to put in a little bit more effort to
access uncle amiibo the Rumbo looking
robot that allows you to use your
figurines within the game you'll need to
first complete the world that you want
him to appear in once unlocked chat with
him a bit in addition to giving you the
location of a power moon somewhere in
the world specific amiibos will also
grant you some costumes as well so here
are all the outfits you'll be able to
get with your amiibo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's all there is well I'm sure we
would have all looked to see Mario just
up in shovelknight or kept in falcon
clothing
I think the waluigi outfit is just fine
if you're craving more mario stuff
though you can check out our review as
well as tons of other features on
gamespot.com my name is Joey and thanks
for watching
[Music]
you